the movie begins with pan a young lady
who sits in front of a mirror doing her
makeup afterwards she proceeds to write
a letter presumably a self-destruction
note Pam then goes over to her bed with
a knife in hand to commit the
unthinkable but suddenly she hears a
tremendous bang outside prompting her to
stop what she is doing and peer out the
window through her shock she Witnesses a
man free fall onto the roof of a car and
die the scene then cuts to a busy shop
where a movie scriptwriter named Domi is
seen searching for a horror movie to
watch dami always wanted to become a
writer because his parents wrote his
name so badly however the shop owner
Nida suggests that he relax and watch
some soothing films instead she also
teaches him to laugh maniacally as it
helps to let out stress later as dami is
buying some movie discs from the shop he
comes across a leaflet called who are
you he curiously asks what it is and
Anita suggests that he look it over
claiming it contains the secret to
happiness following this mommy heads
over to a bookstore where he
surprisingly runs into Nita again this
time she invites him to her home and he
happily accepts but as they arrive he
feels uneasy in the dark interior filled
with several animal exhibits in the next
scene Nita offers him snacks and the two
talk about her son Tom it's revealed
that the boy has not left his room for
the past five years as dummy tries to
process this information suddenly they
hear a thud coming from Tom's bedroom
upstairs however Nina completely ignores
it and dami also departs after this she
goes upstairs and reassures her son that
dami was only a visitor and that he
meant no harm the next day pan sees her
mother with another man and becomes
enraged it turns out her father died
recently and this is the main reason why
her life has been spiraling out of
control in the afternoon Nita is seen
buying groceries in the market when the
street vendor strangely opens up and
expresses her discontentment with her
life upon hearing this Nita gives the
woman the same who are you pamphlet and
suggests that she pay a visit to the
address on it Nida claims that it will
improve her life the movie then cuts to
a flashback where Nita is shown calling
Tom for dinner unfortunately he is too
absorbed in playing computer games and
refuses to come out of his room this
frustrates Nita who unplugs the computer
in an attempt to bring him out however
this only leads to Tom threatening to
harm himself if she doesn't leave him
alone revealing the deep emotional
turmoil that he's been struggling with
it's just a bit of Dork rage he'll be
fine back in the present Nita attends
the who are you Meditation Center where
she along with many other members take
part and listen in on the instructor's
advice and experiments to gain better
control over the mind in the meantime
pan vents her disappointment with a
friend online a better mother's dating
habits and about how her father had died
at the same time Domi sees an
advertisement on TV about hikiko Mori
syndrome which is a condition where
children withdraw from social life and
to isolate themselves in their rooms for
extended periods furthermore a public
canal announcement about the condition
also addresses the fact that the people
who have this syndrome tend to sleep
during the day and are active at night
I'm starting to think that I have
hikikomori syndrome shortly after the
director of the film company that dami
works in enters his office and reads the
script that he has written it is then
revealed that dami has already written a
script and based it off of Tom's life
who has been confined in the room for
the past five years however before
accepting the script the director tells
Domi to get Tom out of his room to film
a TV show dami immediately accepts the
offer and meets with Nita he brings up
the hikikomori syndrome which he
suspects is the root cause of Tom's
condition he then proposes that the
boy's star in his new TV show hoping
that it will help him overcome his
struggles Domi also points out that
Nita's overprotectiveness may have
contributed to her son's condition the
latter is initially hurt by his commas
but with a little convincing she agrees
to the offer however Juanita tries to
get Tom out of his room he refuses and
shockingly slides a threatening note at
of his room written in his own blood
damn Tom raised the stakes he also sends
his severed finger on a piece of paper
worrying Nita God damn he raised him
again despite this Domi is still
determined to get Tom out of his room
and he bangs on the door demanding him
to open it this leads to a heated
argument between Domi and Nida which
soon escalates into a physical fight in
the chaos she falls down the stairs and
gets knocked out as Domi rushes to help
her at the door to Tom's room suddenly
opens and he is pulled inside after this
the evil boy knocks Tommy over and
brutally eliminates him with a butcher's
knife in the 60s we had
and today we have
Nita eventually regains Consciousness
and sees Tom coming down the stairs with
the knife in hand and a bloody towel
covering his face she slowly approaches
him and takes off the towel when all of
a sudden she jolts awake in her bed
revealing that the whole thing was a
nightmare meanwhile pan looks at her
window and notices policemen going
around the place as it turns out that a
robbery had taken place last night her
mother arrived soon after and reminds
pan that she has a doctor's appointment
later the same day it's then revealed
that pan has a severe allergy and that
her condition has forced her to stay
home most of the time it is also
revealed that pan and Nita live in the
same neighborhood so two police officers
arrive outside Nita's house to question
her regarding last night's robbery they
enter the home and are immediately
creeped out by the Eerie animal
sculptures lying around the officers
asked Nita about the weird decorations
to which she simply states that they
belong to her deceased husband who was a
zoologist the same afternoon Nita
luckily rescues pan from a near-death
experience when a bike almost runs over
her on the road later she meets Pan's
mother and finds out about her allergy
so she hands over the who are you
brochure hoping it would help cure Pan's
allergies that makes no sense however
assuming that the whole idea is voodoo
and nonsense the old woman dismisses the
matter a while later when Pam is still
alone at home Nita pays her a visit she
finds out that pan has read the brochure
and tries to convince her about the
power of the mind she even hypnotizes
pan for a brief moment and teaches her
how to gain full control over her mind
so that she can achieve happiness after
a while pan comes out of the trance and
shares her Delight in learning the
meditation program but then she suddenly
inquires about Tom's condition and
whether or not he is still confined in
his room leaving Nita unsettled the
movie then shows us a flashback where
Nita expresses her frustration to her
husband but the dirty state of their
home she is even more angry about the
fact that her son refuses to get out of
his room as their argument escalates
Nita storms off into her room and goes
through her husband's bag to her shock
finds suspicious lingerie along with
photographs of her husband with other
women Nita immediately confronts the man
regarding this but he responds with
physical violence as all of this unfolds
Tom can be seen observing them through a
hole in the Floor of his room back in
the present Nida engages in a
conversation with the who are you
Meditation Center trainer lady she
shares her recent and recurring
nightmares that have been affecting her
lately to which the trainer responds by
saying that it might be the result of
Nita's lingering thoughts and emotions
she then suggests that Nita should
accept her previous pain and Trauma that
she has been supposedly suppressing
within her afterwards Nita heads to her
store where she meets with two
foreigners looking for movies when she
finally understands what they are
looking for Nida gets frightening
visions of her dead husband prompting
her to close up shop and head home
following this we are taken to the first
scene of the movie where pan writes her
self-destruction note and prepares to
end it all meanwhile a random delivery
boy enters his apartment room and climbs
into the attic it turns out that he is
there to take several photos and videos
of Tom from above as he snaps a picture
he shockingly discovers an eye staring
at him in a state of panic the delivery
boy tries to hurry back but only ends up
falling into an adjoining room alarming
all the neighbors including pan he then
attempts to run away from the balcony
but a neighbor mistaking him for thief
shoots him down this causes the delivery
boy to fall onto a car below killing him
on the spot pan sees all of this through
her window and is taken aback however
she gets even more worried when she
realizes that her cat has gone missing
so in order to look for it pan decides
to step up to her allergy and venture
outside on her own for the first time
initially she has trouble walking but
then she remembers what Nita had told
her the other day about controlling her
mind and becomes confident after a while
pan eventually reaches Nita's house and
enters it in hopes of finding her cat
she luckily does find it but instead of
returning home she decides to inspect
Tom's room to Pan's horror she comes
across a smelly 80 Kang corpse on the
chair it appears as if the boy died long
ago disgusted and terrified by the sight
pan hides behind the stairs quickly in
the next scene Nita finally returns home
but learns that she has been followed by
a man she quickly rushes inside her
house but the man manages to get inside
it is then shockingly revealed that the
man is actually her husband who turns
out to be alive after all these years in
another flashback scene Nita confronts
her husband after finding out about his
Affairs she points a rifle at him
threatening to shoot but the man is
unfazed unfortunately during their
argument she accidentally lets off a
shot from the rifle inadvertently
hitting Tom the couple immediately
rushes to the boy's room but it's too
late as he has already died from the
gunshot wound meanwhile in the present
Nita's husband tries his best to
convince her that Tom is dead but she
refuses to listen to him thinking that
her son is Alive and Well in his room so
to prove himself the husband makes his
way up to Tom's room where he discovers
the boy's decaying body in front of his
computer the corpse is placed in such a
way to seem as if he is playing games
unfortunately before the husband can
make sense of the situation Nita
ambushes him from behind this
immediately kills him and his falling
body pushes Nina down the stairs the
entire scene is witnessed by pan who
nervously watches through the bathroom
window she eventually comes out but is
suddenly chased by Tom's deformed alien
looking corpse pan quickly climbs up the
vent in order to escape but the brittle
ceiling of the apartment quickly
collapses leaving her hanging onto a
wire the resulting debris causes a sharp
object to fall onto Nida and She lays
there injured reminiscing about one of
the nights when she and her husband are
celebrating their son's birthday on the
other hand the destruction of the roof
exposes Tom's corpse to sunlight and as
a result he is reduced to ashes the next
day it's revealed that Nita had been
placed in a psychic Ward due to the
mental illness she had developed as a
result of her son's death it also turns
out that Pan's mother had undergone the
same mental illness as Nida the movie
ends as she sits outside her door asking
for her favorite food Sunny Nut Cheerios
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching